comment aller
j'en peux plus j'en ai ras le cul là du
coup finement bordel comme toute la
france comme toute la planète
aujourd'hui vidéo mais gueule je vais
préparer des petites scènes qui sont
scandaleuses du conte est confiné mais
qui vont nous faire du bien parce que
c'est celle font comme s'il n'y avait
pas de confinement là par exemple j'aime
date d'un restaurant en face de moi se
trouvera quelqu'un sur ma gueule on va
prêtant des touristes hors ensemble
autour d'un bon petit dîner et c'est
grave là le mental briques d'un deal
arrive à grands pas j'ai l'impression
allez c'est parti
installe toi tu veux quoi un truc tu
veux mais je vais bien du chemin du foie
gras directement ça veut se mettre bien
la toile et coquillettes comme toujours
c'est quoi la feuille bas du
compte-tours les changes mais départ au
salon
pour ce qu'il fait car en chine au seo
vivre
ainsi toi c'est toi je te prends quoi je
sais comment me qua non pas possible
achetez vite l'adf à stoke a payé tu
veux quoi franchement ouais bah alors là
je me fais un plaisir là je le dis pas
tu as là dessus bottes et franchement s
est pas le premier qui dit un truc de
riches dallas j'ai eu droit au foie gras
bientôt on va me sortir le caviar c'est
incroyable ça veut semaine bien senti
mon fils mon âge moins bien je vais
arrêter de chercher du coup parce que
voilà mais tu vas tu vas trouver donc
[Musique]
je t'attends pas à si je t'attends si tu
hurles je t'entends
je tente en mai 2 mégas loin et un
aspirateur maintenant on va résoudre ça
temps je peux t'aider il faut que tu me
donnes les codes de ta carte bleue juste
et je peux t'aider
à l'ère du peuple à non acheteurs d'or
du montant oui on a réussi allez
maintenant tu me passes les codes à ta
carte bleue tu peux me passer l'étions
je pense que ça va être plus utile c'est
possible sinon ça va commencer
tranquille tout va bien et toi moi j'ai
fait des bracelets je peux voir des
bracelets brésiliens comme ça oh [ __ ]
ok quand j'étais au collège ou chez plus
quand j'avais vu ça c'était stylet mais
c'est le loup engrais quant à choper le
truc ça va là tu te mets à nous prendre
de haut attention non il m'a dit ah bah
écoutes je te souhaite un très bon
confinement ou là à temps il n'y est je
te laisse payer la note je me casse tu
paie la note voilà ce chao salim el
haddioui avait senti
ce coup ci les fans de l'om toi j'ai
l'impression non pas du tout
il est impassible ça fait du bien la
voir des humains sur ma gueule trouve
pas ça fait trop subir pour vous bon
temps plein à chaque fois que je veux
être comme hegel il ya plein de gens il
disputa j'ai croisé trop de gens sympas
avant tombé sur toi oui mais c'est ça
d'avoir la meilleure des communes qui se
disent ou à les ramener aux papas les
sujets qui fâchent on va pas les sujets
qui fâchent écoute tu vas découvrir la
prochaine scène en avant-première attend
faut que je me place bien est ce que est
ce qu on a l'impression que je joue avec
mon enfant
a atteint réaction je juge que c'est pas
si où cette scène qu'est ce qui est
bizarre
[Musique]
je joue avec mon enfant pourquoi tu nous
regardes nom met pas du sien mais c'est
pas bizarre tu nouveau fixe
c'était très long ce moment au la vache
ça va les gars ont passé un bon
confinement savons nous sommes dans le
jury vous êtes en algérie actuellement
oui
le pick up aux algériens ils obligés
suis là passez vous êtes en confinement
ou pas du coup là-bas où est on nous
sommes en confinement aussi ok d'accord
et bien un gros big up à vous les gars
vous confirmons à vous merci bisous les
frérots c'est bisous uci en lega balles
arrêtées terme mode si toi après
j'espère que c'est une blague je te vois
pas déjà mais si tu as peur
waouh je joue avec mon fils et tu me
crie dessus non c'est une blague sine
die tu m'as fait peur en plus [ __ ]
t'as quel âge as-tu fait peur tu
apparais dans ta caméra c'est un simple
on vous sait réellement devrait hausser
un peu des deux
vous êtes confinés ensemble oui ma
copine on en confinement si tout se
passe bien vous foutez sur la gueule
tous les jours en fait un peu des deux
je te regarde par le switch vers deux
heures du matin
après ça tu me mets confinement je suis
désolé mais je le dis merci monsieur toi
c'est tout bah
c'est pas des brousses toi tu vas te
faire [ __ ] faut pas faire des pouces
titouan en terre moi ça fait vingt
minutes là
c'est une blague au tf estime à
quelqu'un je veux dire bonjour
comment ça va
pas la tête la tête ça devient même ça
c'est tour en
terre mois
mais c'est trop dur non merci qui a dit
s'être bien fait non ah bah je te
remercie j'ai travaillé j'ai dû
détourner sur sable de mer de la
gouaille et là est ce que je peux vous
montrer la prochaine scène vous me dîtes
si elle est bien faite à temps
cette grosse non
voilà on s'occupe comme on peut pendant
confinement j'ai envie de vous dire que
ça soit depuis
elle agit encore d
[Musique]
imagine on croise des
noms je veux savoir quand ils vont
croiser des gens comme avant dans l'est
lyonnais quinny
c'est drôle
parce que quelqu'un à mon cher le kilo à
mon cher ludovic n'allons prendre
longtemps [ __ ] ça aurait été beau mec
j'ai fait une petite chanson je chantais
tout le monde l'équipe et j'ai adoré je
leur ai fait un concert gratuit et est
les gens ce qu'ils paient ah oui j'ai
fait j'adore les gens qui skie pour voir
leur faire préférer toi et moi tout ce
qui touche aux belges en boîte à
chansons je te juste je te skip pas moi
c'est ce que je faisais ce que j'ai
aussi toujours de chanter j'adore les
gens qui ce qui passe était mais ce
n'est pas une chanson s'arrête juste ok
c'est vrai je me suis un peu emporté je
suis désolé
as tu envie voir que c'est un fait qui
connaissait un mois 2 qui pratiqueraient
mais non à ces infimes non mais attendez
roma la
highway alors là c'est squeeze pour de
vrai la caisse dans ses caisses quand
c'est bon je te vois je te vois parler
en fait souhaiter yeux donc sûr que
c'est un bon argument c'est un bon
argument quoi d'autre quoi d'autre ben
écoute ta voix peut-être sourit un bon
argument petites habitudes aussi à faire
des fonds verts rigolo aussi je n'ai que
des bons arguments mais vous êtes vous
êtes en quête effectivement je suis je
suis inspecteur terre vous avez crié ma
couverture dans quel département de
police je peux pas vous le dire c'est le
confinement mais il faut quand même
rester professionnel bien jouer on va
voir si vous êtes un vrai inspecteurs
attention qu'elle livre suis-je en train
de lire
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de titre soitec est ce que
je peux passer dans une vidéo où des
petits groupes sont très bons il faut
que tu m'aides certain moment une
seconde au montage ok ok danse par le
club à tout appel que mon nom non mais
non mais j'ai compris que ma profession
je suis cool basculer c'est trop doux
prénom tenait en quelle année 2006 2006
c'était quoi bon alors attendre réfléchi
première lettre a à alex et
alexandre nom arthur non attends me dis
pas je vais trouver
non mais non non non c'est non c'est non
si on avec mes potos mois une bière
s'était infiltrée au fbi a eu quoi là tu
as to me tirée d'un coup est-ce que je
vais montrer ma pote c'est plus que je
téléphone avec elle est là et lola potes
c'est le jeu que c'est vrai mais tu te
fais la gueule mais en fait j'étais ami
j'étais déguisée en garçon depuis avant
je disais aux gens est ce que ça passe
est-ce que je suis un garçon ça passait
vraiment pas au coeur de nos jeunes
avons réussi l'effet escompté aucun de
nous deux anaëlle armand non je vais
trouver
tiens tiens tiens tiens qui volage qui
est en jeu qui verront qu'ils voyagent
qui bouge
tu as gagné
je sais je sais j'ai trouvé antoine web
[Musique]
et non à la tienne fait au nom de férule
attend laquelle celui-ci a pris le
dessus sur toi moi c'est pour bientôt
non mais attends et j'ai pas de calvi si
tu veux tu peux pas jouer là dessus t'as
pas de calvitie non je vois de calvitie
chez malades enfin
pour de vrai ouais pour des vraies
excuses moi man mon dieu oh j'ai fait
écoute moi bien c'est la gaffe de ma vie
mais je suis désolé je n'ai pas grave tu
as quoi dit moi puisque j'ai vécu des
choses aussi à propos de ça avec une ex
ex moi j'ai un sarcome d'ewing c'est un
cancer des os des tissus mous d'accord
était traitée en ce moment je suis en
rémission depuis 17 mois
babeau
ferrand je suis content au butin est en
rémission depuis 17 mois incroyable
ouais 17 mois et du coup tu as des
contrôles fréquents pour pour voir si ça
reprend et les deux mois tous les deux
mois et pour le moment aucune trace way
a le plus dur est derrière du coup pour
le moment un mec je suis content pour
tard émission ça me fait vraiment
plaisir ça me fait
cool tu fais pas pour t'occuper pour le
confinement ben j'ai appris à monter en
fait et je raconte mon histoire sur
youtube un peu tu vois je fais des
vidéos et j'essaye de parler un peu de
buzz de ce qui m'arrive en fait mon
histoire trop bien c'est quoi la chaîne
un homme fort je profite du confinement
pour me lancer un peu sur youtube ce
jour j'ai rien à faire je fais un de mes
journées donc c'est trop mais un mec de
faire ça je pense que tu va aider
beaucoup de gens en fait en temps ça
c'est vraiment une bonne idée mais qu
est ben qui vient continu les vidéos mec
là je passais trop bien franchement si
tu vas te faire ça merci a bientot et
encore désolé
ah
eh bien nous voici à la fin de cette
vidéo mais gueule c'était trop cool de
croiser des gens c'est de faire
concepteurs de confinement en fait déjà
habituellement ça me fait trop plaisir
quand on fait ses vidéos là mais là ne
parlant et nous voyant quasiment aucun
humain ça fait genre trop du bien
c'était vraiment cool merci à toucher du
cou qui sont venus sur omegle compris le
temps de me chercher de me parler de
vous montrer ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
très cool bon courage pour la suite du
confinement et puis on va finir sur un
fameux switcher je suis plus heureux et
ça m'a épuisé
m
[Musique]